♪ ♪
>> Greg: LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE
FELT LIKE YOU ARE WATCHING A
LAWRENCE WELK RERUN.
SOMETHING FROM THE PAST THAT
HOLDS NO RELEVANCE NOW.
TALKING ABOUT POROUS BORDERS OF
HARDWORKING PEOPLE CLOSE SHOPS
AND RESTAURANTS.
CLIMATE CHANGE PREDICTIONS THAT
NEVER PREDICT ANYTHING?
SORRY, WE ARE DEALING WITH REAL
THREATS NOW.
PROMISING TO SHUTDOWN THE OIL
THAT HELPS FAMILIES DURING A
CRISIS?
GIVE ME A BREAK.
WATCHING TWO CANDIDATES TRIED TO
OUT-LEFT EACH OTHER WHEN NOTHING
LEFT REALLY WORKS.
IT IS SURREAL.
SO LET’S NOTE WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES WERE FOR SO MANY
MONTHS.
CHECK OUT JOE CONCHA’S TWEET.
"THESE CANDIDATES IN DEBATES
DIDN’T ADDRESS THE VIRUS UNTIL A
FEW WEEKS AGO.
WHAT DID THEY FEEL THE TIME
WITH?
DID THEY BASH BIG PHARMA YOU
ASK?
THAT’S A GOOD QUESTION."
>> WE HAVE A BUNCH OF CROOKS
RUNNING THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY.
YOU NEED TO TAKE ON THE DRUG
COMPANIES.
WE TELL THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY.
WE TELL THE BIG MONEY INTERESTS
THAT THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR
PROFITEERING.
>> WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO SUE DRUG
COMPANIES.
>> YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY SAYING
WOW, WHAT AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE
A FORTUNE.
THE DRUG COMPANIES WILL NOT RIP
US OFF.
>> Greg: I GUESS THAT NONSENSE
WOULDN’T FLY RIGHT NOW, OR LAST
NIGHT.
AS WE RELY ON DRUG COMPANIES TO
FIND A VACCINE AND SAVE LIVES.
BUT I’M SURE THAT WAS SOMETHING
ELSE THAT PREOCCUPY THEIR MINDS
DURING THOSE DEBATES.
>>>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
>> IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
>> HE HAS COMMITTED IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES.
>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
>> I HOPE HE IS IMPEACHED.
>> Greg: GOES WITH THE DAYS
WHEN THEY WASTED PRECIOUS TIME
BECAUSE ALL THEY WANTED WAS
TRUMP’S SCALP WHICH PREVENTED
THEM FROM EYEING REAL THREATS
WHICH DO THREE THINGS.
OCCUPIED EFFORTS THAT DISTRACTED
US FROM OTHER THINGS LIKE A
REALLY WEIRD OUTBREAK IN CHINA.
SOME SAW IT.
IT FURTHER DISCREDITED THE MEDIA
WITH ITS BOY WHO CRIED WOLF
ADDICTION.
EVERYTHING THAT IS APOCALYPTIC,
SO NOTHING IS.
IT ENFORCES TRUMP’S BELIEF THAT
THE MEDIA AND DEMS ARE OUT TO
GET HIM BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
OUT TO GET HIM ALL ALONG.
WE SUSPECTED THAT THE DEMS AND
MEDIA COULDN’T WALK AND CHEW GUM
AT THE SAME TIME.
WE WERE RIGHT.
IF ONLY THEY COULD WALK AND KEEP
GOING.
DANA, YOU AND I HAVE TALKED
ABOUT THIS A LOT.
I FIND IT HILARIOUS THAT LAST
NIGHT, I DON’T THINK THEY
MENTION THE PHARMACEUTICAL
INDUSTRY AT ALL.
BECAUSE THEY NEED THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY.
THEY ARE A BUNCH OF HYPOCRITES.
THE FATUOUS HYPOCRITES.
>> Dana: ABSOLUTELY.
FATUOUS HYPOCRITES.
IN ONE OF THE DEBATES, THEY HAVE
HAD SO MANY.
CORONAVIRUS DIDN’T COME UP AT
ALL.
IF YOU ARE THINKING THIS IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING.
IN 2000, NEITHER GORE NOR BUSH
WAS ASKED ABOUT AL QAEDA IN THE
LEAD UP TO THAT, NEVER ONCE BY
THE MEDIA OR IN ANY DEBATES.
BUT WE KNEW ABOUT CORONAVIRUS.
I THOUGHT BIDEN COULD HAVE SAID
I’M NOT DEBATING YOU.
DEMOCRAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
JUST MISSED YOUR IDEAS.
HE GOES TO THE DEBATE.
BERNIE GOT FOAMED --
BIDEN GOES TO THE DEBATE AND
WHAT DOES BERNIE DO BUT PULLS
THEM FURTHER AND FURTHER TO THE
LEFT ON ALL SORTS OF THINGS.
STUDENT LOANS, ET CETERA.
I THINK IT WASN’T NECESSARY.
I DON’T THINK THE DNC HAS DONE
THEMSELVES ANY FAVORS.
OBVIOUSLY IT HAD GOOD VIEWERSHIP
BUT WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS.
PEOPLE AREN’T GOING TO FOCUS ON
THAT.
>> Greg: IT FELT WEIRD.
WHEN BERNIE WAS HAMMERING JOE,
ALL JOE WAS DOING WAS DENYING
IT.
HE KEPT SAYING NO I DIDN’T, NO I
DIDN’T.
AND HE DID ON ALMOST EVERYTHING.
IT WAS LIKE A FIGHT IN A WALMART
PARKING LOT BETWEEN TWO SENIORS
OVER A PARKING SPACE.
>> Kennedy: I KNOW JOE BIDEN
IS TRYING TO PLAY DEFENSE BUT I
ALSO THINK PEOPLE AREN’T BUYING
INTO BERNIE SANDERS OFFENSE.
IN HIS RIGHT TO GO AFTER
JOE BIDEN ON HIS HYPOCRISY
BECAUSE HE REALLY IS FORCING HIM
TO DO A 180 ON SOME PRETTY BIG
ISSUES INCLUDING FOREIGN POLICY
AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM.
MY BIGGEST ISSUE WAS WITH
BERNIE SANDERS SAYING THAT WE
HAVE A DIRE LACK OF MEDICAL
PERSONNEL IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW.
IF YOU THINK IT’S BAD NOW, GIVE
EVERY DOCTOR AND NURSE A 40% PAY
CUT AND SEE WHAT YOUR MEDICAL
PERSONNEL LOOKS LIKE IN TEN
YEARS WHEN NO ONE IS GOING TO
MEDICAL OR NURSING SCHOOL
BECAUSE THEY WON’T BE ABLE TO
MAKE A DECENT LIVING.
I WANT TO GO BACK TOWARD
BERNIE SANDERS ALSO SAID ABOUT
BIG PHARMACY.
IT IS THE URGENCY RIGHT NOW THAT
ACTING EPOXIES COMPANIES AND SET
COMPETITION THEY HAVE WITH EACH
OTHER.
THIS HEALTH CRISIS, TRYING TO
SAVE THOUSANDS OF LIES.
IF IT’S THE COMPETITION WITH
EACH OTHER THAT’S GOING TO GET
US THERE FASTER THAN I WOULD SAY
IT’S THE BEST THING THAT’S
HAPPENING AND THE BEST THING
THAT WILL COME OF THIS IN THE
FUTURE WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO
FAST-TRACK OTHER VACCINES.
>> Greg: JUAN BOTH CANDIDATES
MISIDENTIFIED THE CORONAVIRUS AS
EITHER EBOLA OR H1N1 OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHO DO YOU THINK WON?
THE OLD GUY OR THE OTHER OLD
GUY?
>> Juan: I THINK IT’S YOUR OLD
GUY, THE GUY IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT’S A BUNCH OF 7-YEAR-OLDS.
I THOUGHT BIDEN HAD A GREAT
DEBATE.
THINK LOTS OF PEOPLE.
DANA, I REALLY DISAGREE WITH YOU
ON THIS IDEA THAT HE SHOULDN’T
HAVE SHOWN UP FOR THE DEBATE.
IF HE HADN’T CAUGHT PEOPLE WOULD
SAY HE’S AFRAID.
HE’S SITTING ON THE BALL, TRYING
TO RUN OUT THE CLOCK.
HE NEEDED TO SHOW UP AND HE
NEEDED TO DEMONSTRATE A STRONG,
COMMANDING PRESENCE AND HE DID
IT LAST NIGHT.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT, THAT WAS A GOOD
DEBATE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD DEBATE.
SECONDLY, VERY GOOD DEBATE FOR
JOE BIDEN.
THE NEWS COMING OUT OF IT I
THINK IS PARTLY THAT HE WAS
GOING LEFT BECAUSE HE WANTS TO
WIN OVER BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTERS AND I THINK THAT’S
VERY IMPORTANT.
>> Dana: I DID LIKE IT THAT
THERE WAS NO AUDIENCE.
>> Juan: FINALLY I THINK HE
SAID HE’S GOING TO PICK A WOMAN
AS HIS VICE PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: WHY NOT JUST SAY
YOU’RE GOING TO PICK THE BEST
PERSON?
>> Juan: IF THE BEST PERSON
HAD BEEN A WOMAN FOR ALL OF OUR
HISTORY, SHE WOULDN’T HAVE BEEN
PICKED.
IT SEEMS FOR HIM TO SAY LET’S
GET THE BEST PERSON WHO’S A
WOMAN AND THAT WOMEN ARE
THOROUGHLY QUALIFIED, INCLUDING
ELIZABETH WARREN, KAMALA HARRIS,
AMY KLOBUCHAR --
>> Greg: TULSI GABBARD.
>> Juan: WHATEVER YOU LIKE,
GREG.
YOU CAN MAKE A DECISION.
THAT’S A BREAKTHROUGH FOR
AMERICAN WOMEN IN THIS DAY AND
AGE.
I THINK THAT YOU’VE GOT TO STOP
AND SALUTE IT, ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU CONSIDER THE COALITION.
>> Dana: JOHN McCAIN?
>> Juan: YES, SARAH PALIN IS
THE BEST.
SHE WAS A GREAT PERFORMER.
I WANTED TO SAY HIS COALITION
INCLUDED SUBURBAN WHITE WOMEN.
THEY WILL BE TURNED ON BY THAT.
>> Greg: TURNED ON.
REALLY, JUAN?
>> Juan: I SAID THAT FOR YOU.
>> Greg: JESSE, LAST WORD.
>> Jesse: I DON’T EVEN THINK
BIDEN REALIZED HE WAS COMMITTING
TO PICKING A WOMAN VP.
HE KIND OF WALKED INTO IT AND
SAID YEP, THAT’S WHAT I’M GOING
TO DO.
I DON’T CARE WHO HE PICKS RIGHT
NOW.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO MAKE PEOPLE
VOTE FOR HIM.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST, AND I CAN’T
BELIEVE I’M AGREEING WITH JUAN.
BUT JUAN WAS RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN AT A MUCH BETTER
DEBATE LAST NIGHT.
HE SPOKE AND CLEANER
SOUND BITES.
HE WAS MUCH MORE ELOQUENT, MUCH
MORE IN CONTROL.
HE HAD A MUCH MORE SOOTHING
VOICE.
HE ONLY STARTED GETTING RATTLED
ABOUT 45 MINUTES IN.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AFTER 45 MINUTES
OR LOOKING TO WATCH SOMETHING
ELSE.
HE WAS EASILY PUSHED OVER TO THE
LEFT BY BERNIE SANDERS.
THAT’S WHERE BERNIE DARTED TO
MAKE SOME HEADWAY.
SAID JOE, YOU’VE NOT BEEN
LEADING.
EVEN BEHIND THE CURVE ON
GAY MARRIAGE, THE BANKRUPTCY
BILL, ON WAR, ON TRADE, ON HYDE.
BIDEN GOT VERY DEFENSIVE AND
DIDN’T HANDLE IT WELL.
BUT DO I THINK BERNIE LANDED A
KNOCKOUT PUNCH?
ABSOLUTELY NO.
JOE IS GOING TO TECHNICALLY WIN